Ibn Massud is one of the four that
Muhammad told you to take the Quran
from. Here's my question. Is Usman part
of this list?
>> No.
>> Is Zade bin Tab part of this list?
>> Is Hasham part of this list?
>> No. I
>> Very good. We got somebody who Muhammad
the prophet sleam
told everyone to take the Quran from him
along with three others. And according
to him who Muhammad said take the Quran
from him, he disagreed with what Uman
put in his codec.
>> Does it matter that Ib Massud, the one
who Muhammad said take the Quran from
has disagreement with Usman?
>> Actually, Ib Masoud was wrong at this
point because he was right.
>> Life, do you mind joining me in a moment
of silence? We have just lost Ib Masub.
He was thrown under the bus, ran over.
He's bleeding out, twitching because of
the wheels, broken bones and all. Let's
have a moment of silence for the
companion, the honorable companion Ib
Mass. All right. Uh Ahmed, you're on
stage. What's up, bro?
>> I'm fine.
>> Awesome, man. So, we're talking about
the preservation of the Quran. You think
it's preserved perfectly?
>> Yeah, it's totally preserved.
>> Totally preserved. Life, you got
something to say about that?
>> Yeah. So I've read the hadith which you
have which you have coded and I have a
great interpretation for that.
>> Okay. Well, what about the manuscripts
of the Quran?
>> Yes. So I'm going to tell you something
very important. First of all, we believe
as Muslims that the Quran was preserved
and textually. But the thing is that it
was preserved orally better.
And it was also preserved textually but
textually. But I I do agree that some
manuscripts of the Quran like manuscript
there there are some errors in those
manuscripts. But
>> if some manuscripts have these errors on
a local level, this does not mean that
the whole Quran is corrupted and we uh
couldn't preserve the Quran even
errorally. This is something else.
So I I love to talk about the hadith
first because you have coded and this is
such an important topic and you know
that all these arguments are totally old
nothing is new and the Muslim scholars
have replied so much but you people
don't listen to them so I'm going to
reply now first of all I'm going to
refute your argument about
>> one second one second okay so so we'll
go we'll go slowly
>> cuz we we we did just get done talking a
little bit about this oral side. Um, I
want to I want to touch on the textual
preservation as well and and then we can
also talk about the hadith. Okay. Cuz
sure,
>> both are both are important. I agree.
Both are important. I think textual
textual preservation is extremely
important. Um and and I'm glad that
you're able to see like yeah there are
some manuscripts within the uh uh you
know when it comes to the Qurans like
the son manuscript that have some errors
there and so this is what will bring
some questions to this life. Shoot
throwing an alioop to you man. He's he's
he says that it's the Quran is you know
preserved orally better than it was
preserved textually.
>> Yes. What do you what do you think about
his uh his but he still believes that
it's textually preserved?
>> Right. So what do you So you said that
it was preserved orally uh better. So
would you say that this would go back to
the beginning like for like for example
like the people that wrote the Quran
down?
>> Okay.
>> Did they memorize the Quran orally?
>> Yeah. It just go to the beginning.
>> Right. So those guys would be able to
write down accurately what they heard
Muhammad say, right?
>> Yes. I'm going to tell you something
which you might not know. So first of
all, you know, we Muslims, you have to
listen to me first. So you have to
understand. We Muslims have millions of
people in the world who memorize the
Quran. So, and there are thousands of
people who have chains of narrators just
like a hadith and they say that they
heard the Quran from their teacher and
their teacher heard the same Quran 6,236
verses from his teacher and his teacher
that doesn't that doesn't help you
though. That makes it worse.
>> That that makes it worse because because
you're saying all of these people
memorize the Quran. Did all of these
people memorize what Muhammad said
accurately?
>> Yes. Because thousands of people
>> hold on Ahmed. I don't need a detailed
explanation for everything that you
answer at this moment. I just want to
know you. Do you agree that if you're
saying all of these people memorize the
Quran, you agree that they memorize what
Muhammad said accurately? So what about
the people that wrote my brother? So
what about the people that wrote the
Quran down? Did they also memorize what
Muhammad said accurately?
>> Yes. So the professional scribes of the
Quran used to write what they actually
heard and what was actually precise that
time.
>> Got it. So if I show you something that
they wrote originally and it was erased
and changed, then that would mean that
h how does that work?
>> Show me something right now other than
this manuscripts or you know.
>> Yeah, sure.
Let me
add this on stage.
>> Should I Should I just go ahead and read
some super chats, big dog?
>> No, no, no. I got it.
>> Oh, okay.
Go ahead. Read some super chat, big dog.
All right. All right. So, you see you
see this right here, bro.
>> Uh, top copy manuscript.
>> Yeah. So, this isn't the SA. See, y'all
be watching us. Y'all be thinking we got
the same thing every time and we switch
it up around here.
>> Listen to me. Can I speak for just for a
few seconds? This manuscript copy
manuscript was written like after 200
years, not exactly after the death of
the prophet.
My brother, I'm showing you that if the
writers of the Quran actually memorized
your your argument is that people
memorized what Muhammad said.
>> Yeah. But some people can make human
beings.
>> It doesn't matter. Look, it doesn't I'm
not arguing when a specific manuscript
was scribed. I'm showing you that if
you're saying that these people had uh
miraculous memory and they remembered
what he said, then that means that the
writers would also memorize what they
said as well too. So,
>> but brother it depends on the quality of
these
>> my brother my brother you can't have it
both ways. You can't say everybody
memorized the Quran, but when the people
who wrote the Quran down memorized it as
well, too, made mistakes.
>> It's either some bad writers.
>> You got to let me get into the
manuscript. Please, because you're just
trying to give me You're trying to give
me stuff that's irrelevant.
>> It's not, bro. It's either or. It's
either they memorized what he said
accurately or they didn't. You already
said,
>> so let's So, let's
>> No, no, no, no, not all of it. Listen to
me. So I have to testify this. So you
have to
>> before you go, did the writers of the
Quran memorize what Muhammad said
accurately? You said yes.
>> Yes. Some of them. Some of them
memorized precisely and some of them
made mistakes.
>> Now, now, now some of them, now that I
showed you the manuscript, now it's some
of them. You see, you see,
>> my brother, please give me a second. Do
you see the problem that we have when we
have these discussions with Muslims? As
soon as you asked me for the
information, I present it and now you
shifted and moved the goalpost. So, I'm
still going to ask you about this
regardless. Here in the manuscript, it
says, "You know what we conceal and what
he revealed rather than the standard
reading, you know what we conceal and
what we reveal."
This does fit the overall narrative,
context, and theology of the Quran.
though there was an awkward change of
person in a direct address.
>> Okay. So, can I answer which which so
which one of these claims is right?
>> Can you tell me what is the chapter?
What verse is this by the way?
>> It's right here my brother. Chapter
14:38.
>> And the Arabic word is let me see
instead of
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, this is a mistake I I'm
familiar with that you you are showing
something I already know. I know that
these mistakes were made by some scribes
at that time and they used to add these
things in the manuscripts. I know that.
But the problem is that this doesn't
>> Wait a minute. Wait a minute. I thought
you said Okay. So, so, so let me get
this straight. So, they did make
mistakes when writing the Quran. So then
that breaks your understanding that
everybody memorized the Quran and knew
what said accurately.
>> I didn't say that. I didn't say
everybody. I said that
>> you were the one that as soon as you
came on stage, you said, "I want to let
you know something about Muslims." And
you gave this big number of how many
people memorized the Quran. And I said,
"Can we apply that?" And I said, "Can we
apply that to the writers?" As soon as I
went into the scribes and what they
wrote, then you changed your answer to
try to wiggle out of this.
>> So, I would like I want you to give me a
I want to get I want you to give me a
real response as why you know which one
of these is wrong and which one of these
is right.
>> Okay. So, I have to speak for that. So,
I I'll have to speak for like two
minutes or three minutes without
>> Now it's my time. You can you can you
can you can respond you know but not 3
minutes man.
>> Okay but I have to speak because this is
actually a detailed topic not this is
not something which I have to speak now.
So how I do how do I know that actually
the word in the Quran is instead of
which is a mistake in this manuscript
because brother I have verified you know
not one person not two person not 5% you
can meet thousands of persons in Algeria
in Saudi Arabia in Tunisia which will
say that I heard my teacher saying and
his teacher told him that the word was
urin and his teacher told him and the
same
thing will be told by someone and you
can get this statement from thousands of
people and obviously these thousands of
people these ch narrators and these
chains of narrators are not wrong. So by
bringing 10 manuscripts which contain
some errors or some basic mistakes this
does not break the we use a term in
Arabic which is said which means
something which was transmitted orally
in a great quantity which you cannot
deny. So if there is
>> if there are some mistakes in these
manuscripts like five to six manuscripts
>> it's just not
>> my my brother what did you guys
memorize? Did you guys memorize the
standard reading you have today
>> or
>> all right now has that been has that
been proven to go all the way back to
Muhammad as the accurate original
statement of what he said?
>> Yes. The Burmingium Burmingium
manuscript is dates back to 568 AD to
645 AD.
>> You know, you know the problem with that
statement is these manuscripts that that
that have readings and texts under it
that show that it read different prior
to the Uman's, you know, burning of the
books and etc. Prior to Uman doing that,
we have evidence that these manuscripts
were altered and to change to fit Uman's
standard narrative. So when you say
people Let me My brother, you just went
for like 20 minutes.
When you say that everybody memorized
it, therefore I'm good and I can just
say what they memorize of the Uman's
standard version, you're just basically
saying I agree with Uman and anything
that goes against Uman is wrong.
Anything that goes with Uman is right.
The reason why you think that you guys
have it is because you are literally
forced to conform to the oothman
standard version because he literally
got rid of all the other material that
could help our case to prove him wrong.
Luckily, there is material out there
that survived on the manuscripts and the
lower text as well to prove that this
was conducted. But so much of your
manuscript history has been tampered
with that it's hard to actually pull out
um um uh what the original uh Quran
actually was. So you you think that
you're you're giving me the right answer
by saying, "Oh, it's Um's version.
That's the right one." The problem is is
that we have overwhelming evidence that
there was a version or a reading that
differed from the Umic version prior to
this. So just saying a bunch of people
memorized his version doesn't help you.
So can you give a better answer other
than multiple people memorized his
version?
>> Okay. So can I answer no? Sure. Okay.
I'll listen to it carefully. And this is
also an old argument. I've heard that
many times. So the problem is that you
are saying one name Roman. Brother Roman
was not the only person who invented the
Quran. It is actually thousands of the
companions of the prophet agreed with
man. So ifman
altered something in the Quran we would
we would say like at least one companion
will disagree. But the problem is that
all companions
>> im nob
what did he say? He used to believe that
the last two suras of the Quran are not
actually the part of the Quran. But he
later changed his opinion, changed his
mind.
>> Depending on depending on where life was
to go, I can show you where Ib Massud
and and Abu Dhard disagreed with what
you have today in your Quran.
>> Yeah. Give me like give me like five
minutes cuz he doesn't want to deal with
the manuscripts. He actually wants to
deal with oral. So I think he is more
equipped to have a discussion with you
because he just keeps going back to what
people memorized. But he can only stop
at the oothmanic codeex. I I'm I'm going
pre-thomanic codeex, right?
>> I'm showing you things that existed
before that that were distorted and
changed to match with what he has. If
all you're going to if all of your if if
all of your responses is just well,
people memorized it, so therefore uh
Uman's version is right.
>> I don't I don't think you're able to to
discuss with me. I just want to ask you
this question and then you and Logic can
take it off. When someone's ready to
deal with the manuscripts honestly, then
then we can rock. Are you saying do you
agree that your Quran was not textually
preserved like like you said it was
orally, right? So are you saying was
your Quran textually preserved or not?
>> It was textually preserved like 70% not
100% but orally 100%.
>> Right. So it wasn't 100% textually
preserved. Thank you. Therefore, you
just admitted that your perfect
preservation claim cannot be proven. It
can't be proven, bro.
>> It is it is preserved orally or
>> oral is one of the worst ways to prove
person preservation of a text that you
have.
>> Yes.
>> This is something don't even know right
now.
>> You just you just said your Quran you
just said your Quran was 70% preserved.
That means it's not
>> That means it's not 100% preserved. That
means 30% is 100% because
>> that means 30% of your Quran is not is
not preserved. What do you mean by 30%
of your Quran is not preserved?
>> Textually textually there are some
errors in making many.
>> Okay. So So what do you just make it a
little bit more clear? What do you mean
by 30% of your Quran is not preserved?
>> No, if it doesn't matter because we have
evidences for the oral preservation. We
and we have, you know, like not one
person. Not one person.
>> It's okay. It's okay, brother. All All
you know is what is oral. Everybody
remembers stuff. We don't need words. We
don't need letters on paper. It's It's
fine. Logic, you I'll talk to the next
guy.
>> Okay. Um yeah so you have Ib Massud
Quran disagreeing with uh with the Quran
that you have today
right so what what you're saying traces
back to Uman
>> no Iban Mas listen to me you you'll
speak always but you don't let me speak
so I masro was a companion who used to
disagree in the beginning
>> I know who I mass I know who he was you
don't have to tell me who he was
>> no I'm telling you that he used to
disagree in the meaning that the last
two suras of the Quran al and are he
used to say that these two suras are not
from the Quran but he changed his mind
later
>> okay that's cool and all but look at
this
>> yes
>> narrated Ibrahim the companions the
companions of Abdullah bin Masoud came
to Abu Darda
he looked for them and found them then
he asked them who among you can recite
as Abdullah recites they replied all all
of us. He asked, "Who among you knows it
by heart?" They pointed at Alchem. Then
he asked Alchema, "How did you hear
Abdullahbin Massud reciting Sah Alen?"
Which is 92:3.
Alka recited by the male and the female.
Abu Darda said, "I testify that I heard
the prophet reciting it likewise. But
these people want me to recite it and by
him who has created the male and the
female.
>> Yeah.
>> But by Allah I will not follow them.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So can I take I
know this. I know this
with what you have today.
>> So we what we most Muslims believe is
that the vers this verse
in the Arabic in Arabic. So this verse
is proved by the pro by the prophet
peace be upon him in two ways and both
of the verses are correct. So some some
companions heard it.
>> I'm I'm not I'm not interested in you
saying both are correct. My only
interest is did the companions disagree
with what you have in your Quran? Yes,
they used to disagree and it's sad.
>> So remember you said that none of the
companions disagreed with what Uman put
into the Quran and yet we have the we
have some of the companions disagreeing
with what Uman had in the Quran.
>> Only one person and he did not disagree
totally just one or two suras. Just one
or two suras.
>> So now it's just now it's just one or
two suras. Notice if there's it doesn't
matter if it's one or two suras, one or
two ayat, uh uh one word of an ayat. If
they are disagreeing at any form of what
Uman put into the Quran, that gets rid
of your point. Hold on. That gets rid of
the point that you made that all
thousands of the companions agreed with
Uman's with Uman's codeex and none of
them not one disagreed with what Uman
put into his Quran. We have a couple. We
have Ibasud and his crew with Abu Darda
disagreeing with what Uman had in his
Quran.
>> Okay. So, I'm going to answer now. So
you know how many companions there were
at that at that time one hand
>> but you cannot bring just only like
three persons even m okay so what about
you know like
or you know what was his name
and many you you've left thousands of
people and just bringing only one or two
person from an unknown hadith and saying
no this is this is not
>> you said you said an unknown hadith
>> yeah many Muslims don't even know this
hadith even this wait time time out time
out you Muslims being ignorant of your
own sources says nothing about the truth
in regards to your old sources I don't
care how many of you guys know it or not
it ex it's there it's in Bkari this
isn't some unknown hadith bukkari
collect did this right?
>> Yeah. Albkari.
>> Okay. So, this isn't unknown. Maybe you
guys, like you said, you and even some
scholars don't know about this, but this
is known by one of your by your most
authentic collection of hadith. And so,
therefore,
>> right? So, with within this hadith, you
don't just have one, you got Abu Dha and
the people who learn the companions of
Abdullahbin Massud. So you have Abdullah
bin Massud and his companions and Abu
Darda disagreeing with what Uman put in
his Quran disagreeing with what you have
in your Quran today.
Okay brother, now you have to listen to
me. Let's say I don't know. I don't know
anyone from the companions. I don't know
anyone. But the point is that when we go
to when we travel to any Muslim country
in the world like Saudi, Algeria,
Tunisia, anywhere we will meet when
million students who memorize the Quran
with chains of narrators who don't even
mention orb but the the chains of
narrators go back to the prophet peace
be upon him and they tell his teacher
told him that the prophet read the Quran
this way and his teacher told his
teacher that the prophet read the Quran
this way and we have millions of
examples not like you are bringing just
one reference or two and this is natural
so people
>> you know who is
>> yeah he is a companion but he was not
infallible
>> no no what's what's special about Ib
Masoud what what makes him sorry what
makes him unique what makes Ib Masoud
unique
>> Ib Masud used to teach the Quran he was
a Quran teacher and he used to There was
there was a few there was there are a
lot of Quran teachers. What makes Ib
Massud special?
>> Ibn Mass narrated many hadith.
>> That's not what makes him special. Aisha
also narrated many hadith. So did Abu
Huda. Who cares? What makes Ib Masoud
special? Do you know?
>> I didn't say he's special.
>> I know you don't. Um, so you don't you
don't know what make you don't you
didn't even know that Ib Masud is
special. Let me show you. Okay,
>> show me.
>> Let me show you. Okay, this is Jamy
Turdy 3810 narrated Abdullahbin Ammer
that the messenger of Allah said take
the Quran from four from Ib Masud
Kab Muad bin Jabal and Salem the freed
slave of Abu Huda. Ib Masoud is one of
the four that Muhammad told you to take
the Quran from. Here's my question. Is
Usman part of this list?
>> No.
>> Is Z bin Tab part of this list?
>> No. Not according to this hadith.
>> Is Hasham part of this list?
>> No. Only for
>> very good. So what we have here is not
just some flimsy companion of the
prophet who used to recite the Quran or
even teach it.
>> I agree.
We got we got somebody who Muhammad the
prophet sleam
told everyone to take the Quran from him
along with three others and according to
him who Muhammad said take the Quran
from him he disagreed with what Uman put
in his codec.
>> Can I speak now? My question it is a
very important question. Does that
matter?
>> Why the other three people?
>> I don't care about the other three right
now. I I care about I care I care right
now. We We could get into Kab later
disagreeing with what Utman had. Right
now I'm focusing on one of these one of
these four. Ib Massud. Does it matter
that Ib Massud, the one who Muhammad
said take the Quran from has
disagreement with Usman? Does does that
matter?
Yeah, actually I Mas was wrong at this
point because he was right.
>> No, what is the problem? He was not
infallible. He was not an angel. He was
not a prophet. He was just a companion,
a great companion and a great messider
who was according to the prophet a great
messer of the Quran. It I'm not saying
that it it is something unimportant.
But the point is that why Mr. Wood is
disagreeing when other millions of the
companions are agreeing and we have
millions of peoples today we who testify
that this Quran is from the prophet
through the chains of the narrators and
their brother.
>> All right Aman thank you so much. I got
a lot of guests to get to. I appreciate
your uh you you engaging man. Appreciate
it. Appreciate your demeanor. You were
very respectful. So, uh, appreciate, you
know, took last game. Just last game.
>> No, no, that's it, brother.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's it. That That's it.
That's it. That's it. I got to get uh I
got to get moving on. I got to move on.
All right. I appreciate you, though,
man. God bless you, bro.
>> Uh, life,
do you mind joining me in a moment of
silence?
>> Yes. Because
we have just lost Ib Masud.
Ib Massud was
he was a good companion.
He
um
he was really invested in Islam
and um
really close to the prophet.
Ib Massud
did what a lot of people didn't do
and he fought against the grain. He
stood up for the word of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala.
and he's just been ran over by the bus.
He was thrown under the bus, ran over.
He's bleeding out,
twitching
because of the wheels,
broken bones and all. Let's have a
moment of silence for
the companion, the honorable companion,
Ib Masud.
See you in another life, Evie, man.
Sorry it had to be you. Sorry it had to
be you, Evan Mass.
We're sorry. Even though
Even though
even though the prophet himself
told us to take the Quran from you.
Oh wow.
We have Muslims today
that are denying,
that are rebelling,
that are throwing behind their backs
mass.
>> THE PROPHET
SAYS
told us to take the Quran from you
himself.
But unfortunately,
Ibn Mass Masud was wrong. Ibn Massud was
off. He has been usurped
and taken over
by Uman Ben.
I wonder if this is from like Wahi when
he was saying this. You know what I
mean? cuz it's like
I mean they don't believe that Muhammad
can make mistakes, you know, major m you
know how they play games. But like I
mean I I I would assume if this person
who y'all think is getting revelation,
if he tells y'all who to take the Quran
from, I don't think that he would be I
don't think he would make a mistake on
that.
But here it is, ladies and gentlemen.
The guy that Muhammad told you to take
the Quran from, a Muslim, because he has
to uphold this lie, has said that the
person that Muhammad said take Quran
from,
made a mistake
>> when he's just trying to tell y'all what
to take from the Quran.
And so
I if if the notice what this means. If
the dude that Muhammad told you to take
the Quran from makes mistakes in the
Quran,
>> then that means that Muhammad made a
mistake by pointing to Ib Massud
>> for you to take the Quran from.
>> Wow.
Muhammad made a mistake by saying,
"Yeah, take the Quran from this guy."
Wow.
What a religion. What a religion indeed.
What?
My grandma's watching this. She dying
laughing right now. What a religion.